Illyrio mopatis was born in the free
city of Pentos in his younger years he
found work as a cell sword it wasn't
until later in life that he acquired his
fortune in 297 AC Illyrio invites the
two remaining members of the Targaryen
dynasty to his house in Pentos and in
298 AC he presents the exiled princess
Daenerys Targaryen with a priceless gift
in a game of Thrones Magister Illyrio
mopatis gifts the young bride with three
dragon eggs as a wedding gift according
to him the eggs were from a shy and have
been turned to stone over time at this
point in history it has been more than a
hundred years since the last dragon egg
was known to have been hatched
until recently we have had no real way
of deciphering whether or not Illyrio's
story was true did the dragon eggs
really originate from a shy as he told
Daenerys George RR Martin's most recent
book fire and blood seems to indicate
otherwise after the death of her brother
Aegon Rana Targaryen would eventually
went and drove Arman her third husband
he was an unremarkable man neither
strong nor clever he was also nine years
younger than Rana Targaryen it is
implied in fire and blood that though
Rana married Andrew in truth she had
eyes only for his sister Elissa farman
who was everything her brother Andrew
was not over the years a rift would
eventually grow between Rana and Elissa
however the day Queen Rana denied
Alyssa's request for enough gold to
build a ship and sail across the sunset
sea marked the beginning of the end
eventually
Elissa announced that she would be
leaving dragon stone she dreamed of
sailing the sea Rana hid her emotions
well and Elissa depart at the next
morning for drift mark after that point
she was never seen in Westeros again
it wasn't until a fortnight later that
they realized what Elissa firemen had
done three dragon eggs were missing
there was no trace of them even though
they searched for days Queen Reina was
enraged she banished sir maro bullock
commander of the castle garrison from
Dragonstone along with his son and a
dozen others she thought to be
suspicious it was said she screamed at
her husband and roof Armand so loudly
questioning him on what he knew of his
sister's crime that her shouts could be
heard echoing all through the walls of
Dragonstone she even sent men to drip
mark in pursuit of Elissa but the trail
had gone cold
Elissa had vanished somewhere in Pentos
fire and blood seems to imply that the
three dragon eggs that Elissa farmen
stole from Dragonstone were the eggs
that would eventually hatch into ragel
the Syrian and Rogan more evidence comes
in this same chapter when Rana flies her
own dragon dreamed fire to King's
Landing to tell her brother King
jaehaerys of what ELISA had done Raina
knew that it was a ship ELISA wanted not
the Dragons themselves it was most
likely that she would sell them for gold
the King's fear was that more dragons
would soon hatch who had no allegiance
to House Targaryen he worried that new
dragon Lords would appear to possibly
challenge them it was grand maester
Bennifer who suggested that the eggs may
in fact not hatch it was gold she wanted
gold to build a ship she will sell the
eggs they are worth a fleet of ships Jo
Harris had received his sister in his
sole arm with only grand maester
Bennifer present to bear witness to what
was said if those eggs should hatch
there will be another Dragon Lord in the
world one not of our own house they may
not have been aforesaid not away from
dragon stone the heat it is known some
dragon eggs simply turned to stone here
maester Bennifer reveals that it is
known that some dragon eggs merely
turned into stone went away from the
island something about dragon stone
facilitates their incubate
perhaps this is the reason that the
ancient Targaryen chose the spot
nevertheless if the Meister was correct
and the eggs did become stone this is
yet another hint that these are in fact
Danny's eggs King jaehaerys in the scene
goes on to say that some spice mongerer
in Pentos will soon be in possession of
three very expensive stones but King
jaehaerys had a plan for if the Dragons
did hatch they would watch the Free
Cities closely and if the hatchlings
should appear they would demand the
return of their stolen property if the
dragons were not returned
then their enemies in the east would
face the flames of dream fire and Verma
Thor but the Dragons never turned up
that is not until centuries later when
Daenerys Targaryen who was born on
Dragonstone herself hatched them in Khal
Drogo's funeral pyre if this theory is
correct Illyria was born in Pentos and
became extremely wealthy there no doubt
it was there he purchased the eggs which
had likely been in the city for more
than two centuries him telling Daenerys
that the eggs came from ash I was
probably no more than a spurious claim
meant to excite the young princess as
for ELISA farmen she would eventually
take on the alias Alice Westhill and
attempt to sail the sunset sea with the
help of Sir Eustace Hightower we will
save the fate of ELISA Farman for our
next video
Illyrio likely had no idea that Daenerys
Targaryen would somehow awaken the
dormant dragon eggs
Danny's ability to hatch dragon eggs
must in some way be related to the
Targaryen history of placing eggs in the
cribs of Targaryen babes for some reason
all the secrets of hatching dragons were
lost to the Targaryen over the ages but
hidden in the texts we can find many
hints check out my series understanding
the birth of Dragons for more details on
how I think Daenerys was able to birth
dragons into the world I believe it was
a combination of outside magical
influence and of course Daenerys his own
genetics that awoke the dormant dragon
eggs
proximity of someone with Valyrian blood
to the dragon eggs seems to be key here
this and no doubt relates back to
ancient Valyrian sorcery the magic that
bound the Valyrian dragon riders to
their dragons initially though it seems
obvious that Illyrio bought the dragon
eggs in Pentos it remains a mystery as
to whoever had them for the previous 200
years thank you guys for watching make
sure you like and subscribe for more
ideas of Ice and Fire if you enjoyed
this video consider supporting this
channel on patreon